Jason Blum and James Wan's new horror
flick Megan has become the Citizen Kane
of killer doll movies notching an
unexpectedly High critics rating on
Rotten Tomatoes but what a moviegoers
and everyday people actually saying
about the film
directed by Gerard Johnstone Megan
focuses on a toy company robust assist
named Gemma who creates a life-like doll
that runs on artificial intelligence
according to the Rotten Tomatoes
synopsis Megan can listen and watch and
learn as she becomes friend and teacher
Playmate and protector for the child she
has bonded to if that didn't sound
creepy enough Gemma actually decides to
give her own eight-year-old niece the
first Magnum prototype leading to some
horrific consequences you should
probably run Rotten Tomatoes critical
consensus describes Megan as being
unapologetically silly and all the more
entertaining for it calling it a rare
horror comedy that delivers Chuckles as
effortlessly as chills it sounds like
you're fighting we're not fighting but
everyone knows critics and moviegoers
can often have different opinions when
it comes to mainstream films however it
seems that Megan is also a hit among
General moviegoers with the film being
praised far and wide on social media one
Twitter user said after much more
careful thoughts and consideration Megan
has my first five star of 2023 I can't
stop thinking about this film going to
re-watch Sunday another user tweeted
y'all Megan is the goods simple elegant
gnarly there is a scene of such dramatic
tone or shifts that works so well that
I'm honestly in awe such good writing
and filmmaking one user even declared
Megan is a perfect movie while another
singled out the music posting Megan has
some of the craziest needle drops of the
Year overall it seems that most people
who come out of Megan are actually
loving the horror flick and the holding
back their love for it the general
consensus is that it's a movie that
doesn't take itself too seriously and in
similar fashion neither should audiences
which is exactly what's happening going
into Megan most people seem to
understand that this isn't some dramatic
character study as one Twitter user puts
it Megan is Camp pure Camp it would have
been way better if it was rated R
because I could tell that the movie was
restrained and holding back with the
violence and kills but I still had a
good time watching it oh really it can't
be good time it's a common refrain one
reddits are posted I honestly loved it
I'm surprised at how deftly it combined
horror and comedy the movie definitely
doesn't play it straight but that works
here in a way that doesn't in a lot of
horror movies it wins quite a bit
another of the sights users wrote this
was the most fun I've had with a new
horror movie in ages Megan slow descent
into madness was fantastic the blending
of comedy and horror was done about as
well as it could be genuinely very
surprised with this one when making
Megan director Gerard Johnstone made
sure to create a movie that was both
self-aware and campy but also enjoyable
and actually good at this same time he
told collider in a January third
interview well the world already has ex
machina and I don't want to make
anything like Chucky or Child's Play So
Jon Stone tried to find a happy medium
reasoning Megan is just somewhere in the
middle of those things it's really fun
it's self-aware and it's offbeat and
those are the flavors that I like the
most
[Music]